durch die krise ist die kanzlerin
tatsächlich immer emotionaler geworden
die dynamik in ihren reden war ja über
jahre hinweg eigentlich immer die
gleiche sehr die zahlen referiert sie
hat gesagt was die regierung macht das
ist gut so dankeschön
heute hat man gemerkt dass ein konzept
dahinter ist das ist jetzt nicht das
ganze erste mal aber man merkte dass die
dramatik zunehmend ja die zahlen
referiert den pflichtübungen in seiner
rede
sie hat den eu-gipfel referiert aber sie
hat klar gemacht wir brauchen in
besonderen zeiten besondere maßnahmen
dann hat sie versucht ein wenig hoffnung
zu welchen erstes licht am ende des
tunnels wenn wir weitermachen und sie
hat sich interessanterweise durch einen
zwischenruf von alice von storch aus der
fdp-fraktion hinreißen lassen zu einem
geradezu emotionalen ausbruch
sie glaube an die kraft der aufklärung
sie glaube an die wissenschaft und die
wissenschaftler die der bundesregierung
sagen die kontakte müssten runter hat
dann ein ausflug in ihrer biografie
gemacht etwas was sie früher immer
vermieden hat sie wollte weder als
ausdrücklich frauen noch als ordnerin
wahrgenommen werden das hat sie heute
völlig über bord geworfen und hat da
sind die waagschale geworfen um klar zu
machen wir müssen etwas machen das
überzeugend bei jedem angekommen ist
muss jeder selbst entscheiden aber es
war zumindest zu spüren dass da eine
dramaturgie dahinter war dass ein
szenario dahinter war dass dynamik und
druck dahinter war dass hat man über
lange jahre bei angela merkel vermisst
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren